today the Matt wall show protesters
swarmed outside my speech on a college
campus last night screaming that my
presence threatens their very existence
I want to talk about that Clan today and
what they really mean by it also Tucker
Carlson interviews Kanye West Joe Biden
releases from prison anyone convicted of
simple marijuana possession which is to
say he released no one from prison the
media is perplexed that Republican
voters in Georgia aren't abandoning
Herschel Walker following the media's
smear campaign in our daily cancellation
we will deal with McDonald's latest
promotion the adult Happy Meal all of
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
so yesterday was the second stop in my
what is a woman College Tour this was a
week that began 46 years ago it feels
like with three major medical
associations writing to the doj and
calling for my arrest and the arrest of
the other uh high profile quote-unquote
conservatives who criticized them the
day later Media Matters launches their
smear campaign exposing the long
suppressed fact that I was once 23 years
old and finally yesterday I screened the
film and spoke at University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign and protesters
swarmed outside the auditorium doing
their best unsuccessfully to disrupt and
kind of drown me out
frankly the events of this week are
they're making me start to suspect
that there are some people in this
country who really don't like me and I
still can't imagine why that would be
the case I'm such a lovable guy
but the protesters last night were
vastly outnumbered by
supporters by people who support when I
say supporters I mean supporter people
who support uh
you know objective truth and rationality
um we fill the room to its capacity of
350 350 people and we had to turn 400
more people away wasn't all that long
ago that I was giving College speeches
to crowds of like 40 or 50 so this has
been an interesting
change of pace and as mentioned
protesters were kept outside the
auditorium were allowed to remain in the
hallway for some reason I'm told they
made a few attempts to get inside the
room and when that was not successful
they settled for chanting and sometimes
even singing right outside the door
unfortunately for the rest of us they
chose a song to sing that requires them
to hit notes
very much outside their vocal range
listen
[Music]
easy
[Music]
the man
[Music]
[Music]
I was interested to see that video after
the event because I heard some of that
noise while I was giving the speech and
I I didn't know that they were
attempting to sing actually it sounded
to me like somebody was drowning a bag
of cats in the hallway and I you know I
was concerned about that and I'm
relieved to find out that no animals
were hurt even if we could not say the
same for our eardrums when it was time
to leave protesters came around to the
exit to you know flip me off and cuss me
out and presenting a compelling argument
ultimately unpersuasive though I think
as we're getting ready to drive away
they came over to the car to chant some
more here's what that looked like
yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know maybe they're right trans
rights are human rights I didn't believe
that the first 600 times it was chanted
but the 601st time really sank in almost
anyway I think I need to hear maybe
another 600 times before I decide but
there's there's one short clip from last
night a couple of short clips actually
that I think are worth more serious
reflection so going back inside while my
speech was still ongoing
somebody with the school I think this is
somebody with the school made an attempt
to quiet the protesters down now it
would have been easiest to just kick
them out of the building as they don't
actually have any right to gather inside
the building with the express intent of
disrupting an event but they were
allowed to anyway remain there um even
though it's actually against the campus
rules to you know be disruptive like
that inside the building campus decided
not to fully enforce their rules feeble
attempts were made to reason with them
but I want you to listen to this
exchange here it is
it is still disruptive to the speaker
inside
we would protect an event similarly okay
this is dangerous you can encourages
so she says him being here is disruptive
to my being as a whole
and someone else off camera who's crying
says that uh I encourage violence and so
I'm dangerous
and they continued with this line listen
well his documentary is descriptive as
soon as a trans community and they're
being as a whole and him being here
makes a large group of the people on
this campus that makes this campus what
it is feel unsafe if you don't feel
protected we don't feel appreciated and
it's disgusting and disheartening
so that's why we're here and that's why
we're going to stand here I understand
[Music]
right so there it is again my presence
is disruptive to her being
and the being of every trans person and
it makes a large portion of the student
body feel unsafe now
um I know that we're accustomed to
hearing this kind of thing from the left
but the mistake we make is to assume
that they're just sort of putting on an
act
that this is all uh you know playing it
up for the for the cameras
I don't believe that they are I I think
this is truly what they think it's what
they believe
we know that college students especially
believe it because they've been
conditioned into this belief system from
birth and so when they say it's
disruptive to my being it puts me a
danger and danger it's a threat they
really believe that that's what they
actually think that's why they're there
now as far as they're concerned
they're very being is threatened by my
ideas and my presence and not just my
presence and my ideas but the ideas
shared by many of the people in the room
but but listen to the phrasing there
because she's not just saying that her
life is threatened
but instead she's saying that her being
is threatened
and she's right in a certain sense now I
am not threatening her physical
existence in the slightest nobody in the
room was threatening her physical
existence in a slightness
but what she really means is that her
conception of her own existence her
perception of herself and of reality her
self-identity are destabilized are
thrown into disarray when they come
within physical proximity of somebody
who will not affirm them
and this is a terrifying thing for her
and and for me too
but for a different reason
okay here's why I find it terrifying
I find it terrifying
that we are populating Society with
people who are this fragile this
helpless and dependent people who cannot
function who are reduced to tears and
paralysis if their internal conception
of reality is contradicted in the
slightest Way by anyone anywhere
what is terrifying is not the prospect
that these people will get out into the
real world and encounter harsh reality
and just fall apart
no that would be a good thing I I wish
that that would happen
for for the sake of society and for
their own sake that they need to fall
apart they need to be intellectually and
emotionally unmade so that a mature and
rational person can rise from the rubble
this is in many ways the process of
growing up
but no the terror the terrifying truth
is that such a collapse will not happen
most likely
they will never encounter the real world
because the real world in our culture at
least has reordered itself to protect
and Foster the delusions of the most
fragile Among Us
this is unsustainable of course
and what it means is that in order to
stop them from collapsing personally
Society will have to collapse instead
it'll collapse because it simply cannot
carry the weight of all of these false
ideas and false assumptions the burden
is too heavy
to cumbersome
this is the outcome of raising
generations of people who believe that
it is the responsibility of every
stranger they come across on the street
to affirm their own self-understanding
you know they say this is what I want to
believe about myself and about the world
and you must tell me that it is true or
else you are a threat to my existence
and to my being
that's what you really meant
and that's why they were gathered with
their signs in the hallway
that's even why they were singing
Bohemian Rhapsody oddly enough
and that's why we must oppose them
no matter what
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
[Music]
Kanye West was interviewed by Tucker
Carlson yesterday it was a wide-ranging
interesting interview worth watching the
whole thing if you haven't seen at one
point he addresses the controversy over
his white lives matter shirt that he
wore with Candace Owens a few days ago
and let's watch that
so you said
um that your father said when he saw the
shirt white lives matter it's great to
see a black man stating the obvious so
by which I think you meant that's
obviously true yeah that my favorite
response because I kept on thinking like
you know people they're looking for a
explanation and people say well as an
artist
you don't have to give an explanation
but as a leader you do yes I think
that's right
so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
it's the obvious thing
seems like a simple enough answer I mean
I don't know
um and and one it's not only simple but
it's a it's one that no critic has ever
been able to respond to
so we know there are a lot of criticisms
of saying White lives matter certainly
wearing it on a t-shirt
but they've never been been able to
actually explain the criticism or what
their problem is with it
um if White lives matter why can't we
say so why shouldn't we say so
how could it ever ever under any
circumstance be a bad idea to affirm the
value and dignity
of human life of any human life
and you can't claim see the critics they
can't claim that uh saying White lives
matter means that black lives don't
matter they can't claim that because
they're the ones who've claimed before
that saying black lives matter doesn't
mean that white lives don't matter
I mean that's that's one of their
criticisms of White lives matter is that
it's not necessary to say because when
someone says black lives matter they're
not they're not trying to say that white
lives don't
well if that's the case then there's no
reason not to say White lives matter
because the same's in the reverse
because you're saying White lives matter
doesn't mean black lives don't
I mean we can we can probably assume
that Candace Owens and Kanye West don't
believe that black lives matter that
black lives don't matter given that
they're both black and I would think
that they probably find that their own
lives are valuable
so the only way to understand the
criticism
is that the critics apparently think
that that any time you're affirming the
value of life
of lives it should be black lives so
what they're saying is you know why are
you saying White lives matter when you
could be saying black lives matter
so if you're gonna be if you're gonna go
out there declaring that lives matter
then uh if you're doing that then then
it's you're wasting time by saying White
lives you should be saying black lives
matter instead
which which doesn't make any sense
especially when
um there's there's no shortage of people
who are out declaring that black lives
matter so you'd think it'd be okay every
once in a while for someone to say hey
you know what by the way a white lives
matter too
oh it's really underneath all this as we
talked about a few days ago I mean the
the reality is like the only reason to
oppose someone even saying that is if
you disagree with it
but the critics aren't going to say that
they're not quite at the point
now you can get away with you can get
away with a lot of anti-white racism in
our culture get away get away with quite
a lot of it
but
we're probably not yet at the point
where it'll be socially acceptable to
just go out and directly say White lives
don't matter at all they're all a bunch
of scumbags and should die you can get
pretty close to that
but the critic but the people who feel
that way certainly certainly seem to
think that they can't go all the way and
actually declare that and so you know
they won't say they'll they'll
come up with reasons why you shouldn't
say White lives matter but we all know
that the real reason the real reason
they feel that is it is that to them
it's just not true
speaking of lives mattering Kanye also
explained his pro-life stance which I
thought was interesting here's that
he just landed in the lanyard's still on
from it and there's a photograph on it
what is that it's a photograph of a
baby's ultrasound
why is that and that you designed that
yes why what does that mean it just
represents life from pro-life
well so you wear it on a badge what kind
of response do you get and good amen I
agree I don't care about people's
responses I care about the fact that
there's more
black babies being aborted and born in
New York City at this point that 50
percent of black death
in America is abortion so I really don't
care about people's responses I perform
for audience of one and that's God
amen as Doug Carlson said and uh that's
another point that is really impossible
for the left to respond to so they just
they just sort of ignore it
and um
and they they get around it by as they
often do by just
declaring the opposite so they they take
the the opposite position entirely
um even though it doesn't make any sense
and um instead they'll say that no
actually it's uh it's racist it's
anti-black to be pro-life
you know pro-life people are actually
racist
along with being anti-woman and all the
rest of it that well let's throw it all
in and somehow it's homophobic too and
everything to be to be pro-life but it's
also anti-black
just like they can't explain their
criticism of the White lives matter
t-shirt they also can't explain that
especially when this Kanye West points
out
you know if the pro-lifers have their
way
if we have our way
if we really had our way and there was
no more abortion across the entire
country at all it all went away and uh
Planned Parenthood was was thrown on the
historical Ash sheep and that was it
that would mean that a lot that many
more black children would be born
and that the black population in America
would increase substantially not just in
numbers now all populations would
increase in numbers white black all
populations if you get rid of abortion
because all races are having abortions
but more than that
black population would increase
substantially in numbers but also in as
a matter of percentage
because right now
um
you know the the black community
accounts for a vastly disproportionate
number of abortions
and so the gains percentage-wise would
be would be disproportionate as well
so that's what your pro-life that's part
of what you're fighting for
meanwhile on the left they are fighting
to kill more black people and to keep
them you know to keep their sort of
percentages lower that's what that's
what they're doing
but that is the pro-black anti-racist
position they say
in this upside down world of ours since
we're on the subject of black lives
matter now's a good time by the way to
tell you about the premiere of the new
Candace Owens documentary the greatest
lie ever sold which premieres uh finally
on October 12th
and this was uh gonna come out way back
in May you may remember but Candace
decided she wanted to do even more with
it even an even deeper dive and that's
what they've been doing over the past
several months and it was worth the wait
I can tell you Candace is going to
expose the Sham BLM organization and all
the false narratives it has driven and
that it has thrived on
but you can't watch it unless you are a
daily wire plus member uh it look it's
it's just true it's it's a true
statement
that and yes I am biased but it's also
true that nobody is making content like
this
nobody else is
I would I would challenge you to come up
with another company someone else
someone out somewhere else in the
conservative world that's making content
like this this documentary could not
exist on any other platform
it's like what is a woman it's something
that needs to exist uh content that
needs to be made but nobody's making it
but us
and that's why we need you on board as a
subscriber helping us in in the fight
there's a reason why when the left is
you know really going hard at a
conservative media figure trying to take
them down it's almost always you notice
someone here at the daily wire Candace
Ben me I mean there's always like some
conservative trending every week
some conservative in media is like a
main character on Twitter every week but
but never for good reasons because
they're trying to take us out and it's
almost always someone here at the daily
wire
um or you know there are a few outside
like Tucker Carlson's another one
obviously
but they're very worried about us and
about what we're doing
because we're in this fight we're
fighting to win we are serious about it
this is not just publicity this is not
just content marketing for us
putting it on the line and uh we can
we can do that only because we have the
support of our subscribers we couldn't
do it without you
with you we can and we can win the fight
together
so this is a great time to become a
member of the daily wire if you haven't
you can you can do that now before
October 12th which is the big Premiere
event and
um there's about to be another daily
wire documentary that catches the World
by by storm and you'll see it for
yourself if you become a member so I
would urge you to do that
all right Politico has this this is
their headline
and uh they're very upset they say
Walkers Hurst this is Herschel Walker
Herschel Walker's Christian fans are
unfazed by abortion Revelations
and it goes into it says Pastor Anthony
George didn't set out to be a defender
of Herschel Walker but as the prominent
Baptist Minister welcomed Walker into
his church this week for a scheduled
prayer event with faith leaders George
found himself making the Christian Case
for supporting a candidate whose Senate
campaign has been marred by personal
scandal what matters most he said is
what Walker is promising to do once he's
elected quote I think that any Christian
who engages in the political process
especially someone who's a pastor you're
always going to be confronted with
someone that is either less than ideal
or something that flat out contradicts
what you believe in you said in an
interview since Revelation surface that
the former football star and
self-described pro-life Republican had
allegedly paid for an ex-girlfriend's
abortion in 2009 Evangelical Christian
leaders in Georgia have banded together
to support Walker as has the Republican
party in general Walker has staked out a
hard line uh no exceptions position on
abortion
Walker's 13-month campaign has been
punctuated by blemishes on his record of
traditional Family Values including
allegations of domestic abuse and
fathering children out of wedlock those
Revelations continued late Wednesday
with a report from The Daily Beast
alleging that the woman whose abortion
he paid for is also the mother of one of
his children
so far Christian Evangelical leaders
have not flagged in their support saying
that he aligns with them on key policy
matters all right
so the media is uh acting perplexed by
this as they always do they put out this
hit piece about Herschel Walker claiming
he paid for an abortion years ago and
this is on the heels of other hit pieces
as they just summarize their claiming
domestic abuse and all these terrible
things
as always the media expects that this
will
immediately make the support for this
person evaporate
but
in this case as has usually been the
case in recent years that hasn't worked
out for them
and every single time
you know in politics
there's a candidate and they're trying
to take the candidate out they put a
bunch of hit pieces and and uh I mean
Trump is the classic example of this but
certainly not the only example they put
out the hip pieces they say look this
person's terrible look at these
allegations we found
and recently anyway the response from
conservatives and from people in the
base is
just to sort of yawn and ignore it
and the media they they can't take it
they're so it makes them feel helpless
and Powerless and they get very
frustrated
because they say what do you mean we
told you this person's terrible you're
not supposed to we told you you're not
supposed to support this person why
would you still be doing it when we told
you otherwise
well let me see if I can try to explain
it for them
so there are two things for this
if I could and I'm not a I'm not a voter
in Georgia but if I were to if I could
if I would dare to speak for them
let me tell you what the thought process
probably is I'm not just speaking for
them I mean I've listened to the voters
in in Georgia and this is what they seem
to be saying so there's two things
number one
to begin with
there's no reason to believe an
allegation just because it came from the
media
it could be true so the claim that
Herschel Walker paid for an abortion
could be true but I mean I don't know I
don't know the guy I know very little
about him actually other than he's a
I know about his athletic career and a
little bit about his political policy
positions but I certainly don't don't
know him personally
don't know a lot about his uh background
in biography so I mean it could be true
it could also not be true
and the the uh possibility that this is
a fabrication or something that this is
a a fabricated media hit piece like you
can never take that off the table you
can never discount that possibility
and so that's the first problem you have
if you're in the media that's and you're
wondering why it's not resonating that's
the first reason is that people hear
that is and you know maybe they that
someone tells them oh did you hear this
claim about Herschel Walker and then
they go well how do we know that oh oh
it was out on uh you know CNN said it
and then the other person's gonna say oh
CNN said it well okay I don't care
now you might not like that if you're in
media but this this you've done this to
yourself there are consequences for your
actions and when you've proven yourself
to be dishonest time and time again
when you've proven yourselves to be
political vultures
uh obviously hyper partisan this is how
people respond to you
that's the first thing
and then and then and then there's also
the second thing which is that
even if it's true
okay let's just let's say for a second
that it's it's true that he's that he
paid for an abortion
terrible terrible thing
awful
an awful moral crime
and uh
should be like a a an actual crime
although at the time when this allegedly
happened it wasn't
so no question about it
but in Georgia you're left with the
voters are left with two choices they've
got Herschel Walker who supports who
supports pro-life policies
and they've got uh Warnock who support
who openly supports rabidly pro-abortion
policies I mean he believes in abortion
up until the moment of birth maybe even
after who knows
so those are the two options
and the voters in Georgia aren't stupid
they understand that those are the
options
and so on one hand you have someone who
supports pro-life policies
and all indications are that he would
support and especially if he's voted
into office on that platform he's not
going to suddenly change and say yup
just kidding gotcha I'm actually
pro-abortion he's not going to do that
he's going to continue to support those
policies
and that is going to save lives
while on the other hand you have someone
who has professed that he wants to kill
more babies that's his intention
um those are your two choices
it just it's there's there's it's not
even a choice there's not even really
anything to think about
I mean even if it were true that
Herschel Walker not only paid for an
abortion a terrible sin
let's just say that that even right now
in his head he's still pro-abortion
again I don't know that to be true at
all but let's say it is this is all a
put on he's Faking It
well even so you elect him as a PR as
someone who supports pro-life policies
that's what he'll do in office
and the effect no matter what he feels
inside his head no matter what he's done
in his past
the effect going forward in the future
is that it's going to protect babies
he might be protecting them while in his
head he might be he might be doing it
begrudgingly he might in his head be
wishing that the more babies were being
killed I mean
but in reality the actual effect in real
in the real world is that is that this
is going to protect babies whereas this
other guy over here is openly saying
let's kill him I want to kill more
so that's it that's uh that's the the
choices so as a if you're a Christian if
you're a pro-life voter in Georgia
you're looking at these two uh choices
you're obviously not going to say well I
don't you know Herschel Walker he might
have paid for an abortion so I'm not
going to vote for him because I'm
opposed to abortion instead I'm going to
vote for the openly pro-abortion guy
that doesn't make any sense
um but you're also probably not going to
say well uh this guy's openly
pro-abortion the other guy may have paid
for an abortion it's a terrible thing
and I'm very anti-abortion so I'm just
gonna stay home
and the effect is that the the openly
pro-abortion guy will win
you're also not going to do that
because you're what you want to do the
thing that's going to help Advance
pro-life policies and the pro-life cause
politically
all right Joe Biden
tweeted this if I could pull it up
um as we head into the midterms you know
look Joe Biden
it's uh not a good situation for the
Democrats everything that they touch
turns to everything of Joe Biden touches
in particular turns to garbage so it's
it's very much he's like the anti-mitis
it's like the opposite of the Midas
touch
and he's looking for something popular
something easy as we go into the
midterms and uh this is what he finds he
tweeted as I've said before no one
should be in jail just for using or
possessing marijuana today I'm taking
steps to end our failed approach
allow me to lay them out
first I'm pardoning all prior Federal
offenses of simple marijuana possession
there are thousands of people who are
previously convicted of simple
possession who may be denied employment
housing or educational opportunities as
a result my pardon will remove this
burden second I'm calling on Governors
to Pardon simple State marijuana
possession offenses just as no one
should be in a federal prison solely for
possessing marijuana no one should be in
a local jail or state prison for that
reason either third we classify
marijuana at the same level as heroin
and more serious than fentanyl it makes
no sense I'm asking uh secretary Becerra
and the Attorney General to initiate the
process of reviewing how marijuana is
scheduled under federal law well that's
that's a pretty firm step right there
that's a productive step I am asking
these two other bureaucrats to initiate
the process of reviewing how marijuana
is scheduled under federal law I just I
love that
classic classic political move of uh
making a big announcement and like
you're not doing anything at all I to
this I right now am going to initiate
the process of assembling a committee to
discuss how we can review in the future
this policy and how it might affect and
okay I'd also like to note that as a
federal and state regulations change we
still need important limitations on
trafficking marketing and underage sales
of marijuana sending people to jail for
possessing marijuana has upended too
many lives for conduct that is legal in
many states that's before you address
the clear racial disparities around
prosecution and conviction today we
begin to right these wrongs well
no today you begin to do nothing at all
so just more of the same
uh that's a big nothing
initiating the process of reviewing is
nothing but even more than that
pardoning people who are in federal
prison for simple marijuana possession
you know when you when when you do that
you know how many people are going to
actually be free now now that this
pardon has been issued
all across the country
how many people this morning are
emerging from their jail cells into the
sunlight
blurry-eyed free again how many I can
tell you what the answer is zero none
none no people there there are currently
but before the pardon and now
no one no people in federal prison for
simple marijuana possession none zero
none at all
that's just it's not a thing okay this
is the the the
proponents of Criminal Justice Reform
have tried to pretend that this is a
thing and it's not sending people to to
federal prison
because they were caught with like a
little bit of weed in their pocket
just not happening
period
I think there have been at least what
the media is telling us is there have
been something like 6 000 maybe 6 500
people charged with uh simple marijuana
possession on the federal level in the
last 30 years
and those are just charges
how many of them actually went to spend
time in federal prison
almost none of them
and those are also charges how do those
charges come about well you have to
figure a certain portion of them it was
the charges that they originally had
were pleaded down
and
uh also another point
simple marijuana possession
is a misdemeanor anyway
and having a misdemeanor is not going to
stop anyone from getting a house
who is being prevented from owning a
house because of a misdemeanor
it's probably not going to stop me for
getting a job it's not going to stop me
from doing anything it's a misdemeanor
that's the whole point that's why we
have that category in the criminal
justice system
it's gonna have very little impact on
your life
so this is it was only ever a slap on
the wrist for simple marijuana
possession that's all it ever was and
that's all it will be now so this does
nothing at all
what's the real Point well the real
point is obviously about virtue
signaling and uh what is the virtue
being signaled in this case
The Virtue being signaled is the virtue
of being soft on crime
and I'm not saying that I think the
people should be going to federal prison
for simple marijuana possession I don't
think that but it's not happening so
it's not an issue
I also don't think but but you know
decriminalizing and legalizing all
across the country I also don't think
that's the solution as we've talked
about recently
there was a time when I kind of bought
into that argument
but I I can look around I mean we we can
see how it's worked out
because as Joe Biden observes
the laws have already been changed in
many states and many cities where
marijuana is either legalized or
decriminalized and people can walk
around smoke away till their heart's
content
and has it helped anything
no the the drug abuse problem in our
city is only getting worse over time not
better
so that's all that's all this is it's
just a it's a big nothing and yet I see
there's even some people kind of on the
right or at least people who are not
full-on leftists I mean Elon Musk was
one that responded to this he didn't say
a lot he's responded with a thumbs up
emoji so it wasn't a huge it wasn't like
a huge celebration but you know there
are plenty of people who are not
leftists who respond to this and I this
is a good this is the right move I
support this
now doing something just for show that
has no other effect that's that's not
something that we should
line up to applaud
all right what else we got
all right here's a little bit of a
celebrity gossip
Gisele Bundchen and Tom Brady are taking
two wildly different Rouses from Fox
News by the way wildly different routes
when it comes to protecting their peace
as they battle marital differences that
could ultimately lead to divorce after
13 years of marriage 42 year old
supermodel was spotted leaving a
holistic healer's office in Miami on
Friday
her appointment didn't end inside the
building though as the natural natural
path reportedly brought a smudge stick
and burned Sage
around punchin's vehicle before she
drove off I don't even know what any of
those words mean
a well Sage I know but a naturopath
what the hell is that
brought a smudge stick
and burned Sage around her vehicle
so she's getting divorced and uh you
know they're giving up on their marriage
and
her solution to make everything okay is
to burn to have a natural path like a
witch doctor come and circle her vehicle
with sage that's gonna make it okay it's
gonna make it okay for the kids right
the kids don't worry dad and I are
getting divorced we're breaking the
family apart but uh don't worry we're
gonna have a lot of appointments with
the holistic healer and he's gonna be
burning a lot of sage and we're going to
get through this together okay
it continues burning sages a
centuries-old ritual from indigenous
people that has been known for
spiritually cleansing a person or space
well no it hasn't been known for that
it's I mean
maybe has been claimed that it's done
that but it just literally does nothing
at all it's that it's it's like
pardoning people for simple uh marijuana
possession it's just a symbolic if
anything
uh bunches alternative lifestyle
includes clean living wellness routines
meditation eating only homegrown or
organic food and getting divorces I
added the second one while Bundchen
cleared her energy Brady reportedly is
tackling his own emotions regarding
their fumbling relationship as a source
told people that uh the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers quarterback feels very hurt
by her amid claims that they both retain
divorce attorney
it's pretty obvious that he's hurting A
source told the publication she's the
one steering the divorce she's playing
offense and he's playing defense he
wants to protect himself protect his
interest but he's only starting to go
the legal route and his defense from her
he just wants to be
he doesn't want this to be ugly he
doesn't want to fight if the divorce is
happening he wants it to go smoothly as
possible well
you know a non-ugly divorce first of all
is a myth it's it is actually impossible
I mean there are there are degrees uh
gradations or what I'm looking for
degradation also is an appropriate word
but there are gradations
of ugliness when it comes to divorce
some are uglier than others but they're
all ugly it's an ugly thing
it's an ugly thing you're dissolving a
marriage there's there's no beautiful
way to do it
there's no really peaceful or
holistic holistically healing way to do
it
and it's a sad story it's it's always
very sad when I read stories like this
not because they're celebrities you know
it doesn't matter but because they've
been married for a long time and they
have kids and so anytime I read a story
I hear about something like this it's I
find it very sad
um and I would hope that I don't know
anything about their situation other
than what you're reading in the in the
news but
I would hope that
Tom Brady's fighting for his marriage
you know fighting for his family
and this is in a certain way it's kind
of a tale as old as time at least based
on the reports about this
tell us all this time when it comes to
divorce but also what what led to it
what caused the rift reportedly was that
um Gisele was uh didn't want Tom Brady
to keep playing football and uh and he
did and she wanted to like focus on her
you know she wanted to be the focus on
on her and her career and he keeps going
with his career and that's what led to
the rift so you see once again it is
it's kind of the difference in the Sexes
yet another difference we're supposed to
pretend doesn't exist
Giselle wants Brady to be home with his
family but uh from his point of view
he's supporting his family by working
and they don't need the money of course
like they could retire and live the 50
lifetimes on the money that he already
has and I'm sure that point was probably
made to him by his wife but um even so
you know that's just the way he sees it
he probably also imagines that you can
be a better role model to his kids by
working than by sitting at home
and at some level these are excuses
because he really wants to play football
but at another level there's there's
plenty of truth to it
so the wife says you need to be home
more you have a family and the husband
says I know I have a family that's why
I'm out working and neither is wrong
exactly but their perspective and
priorities don't match up and
unfortunately on this case in this case
though so there are you know every
married couple has disagreements like
this in this vein
um
but in this case it's led to an ultimate
Calamity and catastrophe
because it seems like they're both too
focused on themselves
which is what always leads to divorce
and in the end
is a focus on on the self rather than on
the vow and on the marriage all right
let's get to the comment sections
[Music]
Barry Sanchez says I hope you played
great music back in your shock jock days
what a freaking joke these people are
don't worry Matt we have your back well
we didn't play great music I
unfortunately would tell you this is uh
you know early 2000s
the early 2000s Rock scene was not
was not great it's kind of like a new
rock I don't know what the genre is
exactly and so as loud as like
Papa Roach type stuff this is what it
was
not wasn't my favorite I'll admit to you
and we played Pearl Jam like Pearl Jam
was at that point you know still older
it's like nine more 90s we played Pearl
Jam probably five times an hour
um Chris O'Neill says Matt used to
record himself and publish it to the
world beardless there is nothing that
you can do to humiliate this man
very good point it doesn't get much
worse than that
and really I have uh it's been ex I've
been exposed in a certain way as a fraud
because
you know now we see that the the sweet
baby gang mascot and symbol of me
bearded
as a baby you know
with a with a beard as a baby now we see
that that was not actually
technically true that has been revealed
foreign
says Matt after learning of your past
escabades I like you even more
dicks Dixie whiskey says it warms the
old bones seeing that Matt was a Proto
troll before it was cool and has honed
his craft over a long career
take some time those take some time to
grow into the into the trolling
anyway there are a lot of comments like
this a lot of very supportive messages
which uh I
do really appreciate
um and it's like we talked about earlier
in the show you know none of this works
without support this is the thing about
you know as we discussed yesterday any
cancellation attempt it's like here's
there are a couple of conditions that
need to be met for a person to be
canceled the first is the one we talked
about yesterday which is that the
canceled person needs to cooperate needs
to consent to it needs to play the role
it's been assigned to him crawling on
his knees begging for forgiveness only
to not receive it anyway and just to be
kicked in the face and told to go away
um so that's the first thing it needs to
happen for the cancellation and the
other thing is needs to happen is that
the person needs to be isolated so this
is this is always the the game with the
cancellation is to isolate the person
you know it's like a predator
in the Serengeti right like find the
sick weak prey who's isolated from the
herd and pounce on them and so that is
always the game it's to make sure you
isolate this person they have no support
and then you can take them out
um
that's why if you have support then you
can't be canceled
which uh which I know that I have so I
do appreciate that but it's also a
lesson for for all of us is why we need
to support each other when the left
comes after us because if we do
then we're Unstoppable
there's my inspirational message
well the corporate media agenda means
the news is presented in a biased way
you know what I know we all know it
thankfully there's a way to get the most
important news of the day without their
narrative and that's by listening to one
of the top news podcasts morning wire
new episodes are available every morning
seven days a week and they cover stories
other media Outlets won't touch it's
starting this Sunday October 9th and
every Sunday until the midterm elections
you can also tune in to election wire
for in-depth coverage candidate
interviews and more it's the most
important midterm election in recent
history stay informed you'll find
morning wire and election wire and apple
podcast Spotify daily wire plus wherever
you listen to podcasts now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
so one of my least favorite memes is the
cartoon of the guy shushing another guy
and saying let people enjoy things the
the let people enjoy things line is
trotted out now on the internet
approximately 46 million times a day
it's always deployed in reaction to
anyone who says something critical about
a thing that other people enjoy
um and I hate the meme because first
it's lazy and unoriginal and second it
implies that somehow you're preventing
people from enjoying things simply by
giving your own opinion about it which
would seem to suggest that an
individual's enjoyment of a thing is
dependent on the encouragement of other
individuals if you need other people to
encourage you in order to enjoy
something that would seem to suggest
that perhaps there's a problem with
whatever it is you're enjoying third
most importantly the fact that people
are enjoying something does not mean
that it shouldn't that it should be
exempt from criticism
all things in existence are enjoyed by
somebody does that mean that nothing at
all can ever be criticized
serial killers enjoy murdering people
can a serial killer give that response
to the judge during trial uh you've been
convicted of 23 counts of Murder in the
first degree
judge let people enjoy things okay
the point is it is valid to scrutinize
the things people enjoy in fact we
should especially scrutinize those
things because it would seem often
redundant to criticize that which nobody
enjoys anyway
I say all this only to head off at the
past the inevitable response today to
today's daily cancellation which focuses
on the newly released adult happy meal
so CNBC reports quote you're never too
old for a Happy Meal or at least that's
what McDonald's is banking on the fast
food Juggernaut at uh this week
announced plans to introduce adult
oriented meals complete with a free toy
in an initiative designed to work off of
The Nostalgia of the restaurant's famous
red cardboard boxes the cactus plant
flea market box is a collaboration
between McDonald's and the Famous
streetwear Brand and will roll out to
participating stores starting on October
3rd unlike the smaller menu items
included in the classic Happy Meal the
cactus plant flea market box will
feature either a Big Mac or a 10-piece
chicken McNuggets as well as a soda and
Fries Inside the Box will be a will be
one of four collectible figurines
collectible figurines of McDonald's
mascots Grimace the Hamburglar and
birdie as well as a cactus buddy quote
we're taking one of the most nostalgic
McDonald's experiences and literally
repackaging it in a new way that's hyper
relevant for our adult fans McDonald's
Chief marketing officer Tariq Hassan
said in a statement well they did just
release their first ad for the adult
happy meal and uh here it is
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
that's an ad that's supposed to appeal
to adults not even just adults on acid
but sober adults too
and it seems to have worked at least at
first apparently the adult happy meals
are selling out all across the country
McDonald's workers have taken to tick
tock of course to complain about all of
the extra work this promotion is forcing
them to do because people are so into it
adults are flocking to the fast food
chain to order their very own nostalgic
box uh they're coming in such numbers
that
as McDonald's employees report it's
creating chaos and stress for the staff
as for the customers the initial
excitement that these grown adults felt
over their Happy Meals has apparently
given way though to disappointment and
not disappointment in themselves for
being so pathetic and emotionally
stunted as to order a damned happy meal
for themselves in the first place but
disappointment over the toys in the Box
so eat this reports quote on paper the
idea certainly sounds intriguing but
early reviews were quick to point out
its shortcomings yes this is not a
nostalgic happy meal for adults this is
weird and artistic and appeals to
teenagers wrote one at Reddit user after
reading about the promotion I was
semi-interested as a fan of tacky
nostalgic knickknacks but these don't
capture the Nostalgia so that so what's
the point added another redditor
it's true when most adults think back to
their cherished childhood memories of
Happy Meals street wear fashion doesn't
immediately come to mind quote there
were so many directions McDonald's could
have gone with the toys that would have
felt special comic book toys Nickelodeon
toys Ninja Turtle toys these would have
turned the Millennia Nostalgia up to 11
Jeremy Schneider of nj.com opined and
it's hard not to agree with him
to be clear
that is an adult a grown man upset that
his Happy Meal didn't come with a ninja
turtle toy
what's next are you going to put on a
Batman costume and go trick-or-treating
and then cry to your mommy because you
didn't get any fun dip in your plastic
orange pumpkin
Actually I don't even want to know the
answer to that question
and see this is the problem
the adult happy meal is yet another
nostalgic brand promotion aimed squarely
at Millennials and it works at least
initially because Millennials My
Generation as a group absolutely refused
to grow the hell up
as a generation we are growing older
chronologically we're experiencing all
of the inevitable physical changes that
come with that we're getting fatter and
slower our hair is thinning we're
developing chronic back pain Etc but
emotionally and psychologically we cling
to the past to our youth to the things
of childhood
First Corinthians says when I was a
child I spoke as a child I understood as
a child I thought as a child but when I
became a man I put away childish things
this is a verse that made sense to and
resonated with most generations of
humans who've lived on Earth but but not
with ours
because we never put away the childish
things we still speak and act and
understand as children
and the result is that we are the most
emotionally stunted generation of
overgrown pathetic babies that have ever
lived on the face of the Earth
many of us have chosen not to have
children of our own instead electing to
be children ourselves perpetually
ordering Happy Meals watching cartoons
obsessed with superheroes and comic
books listening to music made for
teenagers
our tastes have not matured in the
slightest because we have not matured in
the slightest
and of course I use the word we here
only in a general sort of generational
sense there are Maybe
five or six of us who are exceptions to
the rule
now two other points to consider
first Millennials are obsessed with
Nostalgia you know they eat anything up
that reminds them of their childhood
that's why any rebooted Nickelodeon show
or film franchise from the 90s will
attract intense interests from
millennials all of these Disney
live-action remakes seem to Target
Millennials even more than current day
children
though the nostalgic Millennial
inevitably leaves these trips down
memory lane feeling disappointed and
unfulfilled he sobs forlornely over his
Happy Meal because it's not as
delightful as he remembered it being in
his childhood he writes a scathing
review of the latest Disney film because
it didn't live up to his childhood
memories he sits in his beanbag chair
drinking his Sunny D watching The
Rugrats reboot yeah he feels that it's
somehow just not the same
and he's right he was a child then and
he isn't anymore
even if he doesn't realize it he has
deeper spiritual and intellectual needs
and desires today that simply aren't
going to be satisfied by the
distractions of his youth
also his nostalgic remembrances are only
vaguely rooted in reality
Nostalgia is the story you tell yourself
about your past which is not the same
thing as the actual past
and the most pitiful thing about it all
and the reason why he's never satisfied
no matter how much he immerses himself
in Nostalgia is that all of his
nostalgia
is tied to brands
Millennials have a branded Nostalgia all
that they Pine for from childhood are
corporate products
and content
this makes it incredibly lucrative to
exploit but also means that our
nostalgic Pursuits will always feel
empty in the end because they are
here's the second or final point
there is a truly wholesome joyful
fulfilling way
to relive aspects of your childhood and
that is by having children yourself
okay I enjoy watching my children
experience the sorts of things that I
experience in childhood it can be very
fun to go back and ReDiscover the joys
of childhood by experiencing them with
your child so for example
I actually have fun playing hide and
seek or the floor is lava with my kids
that's a lot of fun you know last time I
played that I was like 10 and then my
kids came of age they got to floors lava
age and we could play with the kids it's
fun I'm very competitive in both games
and I can become quite invested in them
but they're fun for me because my kids
are having fun it's something I can do
with them I wouldn't play it by myself I
wouldn't suggest it as a date night
activity with my wife except to annoy
her
I'll also watch the sorts of things I
watched as a kid with with my kids it
can be fun to introduce them to the
shows and films that I enjoyed when I
was you know their age it could also be
heartbreaking if they find it boring and
lame as happened when I try to get them
to watch the original Space Jam for
example
the Damned Philistines did not
appreciate it at all they were bored out
of their minds
I will also have the sorts of
conversations with my kids that I used
to have when I was a kid so my son will
say to me hey Daddy would you rather eat
poop or
get bit by a snake
and of course I want to know like what
sort of snake are we talking about and
how much poop I mean if it's if it's
non-venomous I'll probably take the
snake if it's a diamondback we're
talking about well I I guess I'm going
with the poop and we continue with the
discussion for several minutes
point being
there's a proper way to experience
aspects of your own childhood again and
a way that will not only live up to your
memories but will often exceed them like
I feel like I can actually have more fun
with some of these things now than I did
as a kid because I'm with my own kids
I'll even eat Happy Meals I will eat
Happy Meals as an adult
but I eat them when I order them for my
kids
and I steal half of the meal
before handing the box back to them in
the car
like a civilized and mature adult
okay that's the correct strategy
that is why ultimately the adult happy
meal is today canceled
and that'll do it for us today as we
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]